allons plus loin avec diane poitras
président de la commission d'accès à
l'information du québec ou bonsoir
madame poitras bons soins vous évoquez
donc dans ce reportage un ensemble de
lacunes administratives et technologique
là chez desjardins et comprenait pas
vraiment au sérieux les menaces internes
comment vous arrivé à la conclusion que
desjardins était au courant de cette
faible et cela depuis longtemps ont fait
l'anc est que nous avons effectuées
démontrent qu'il y avait au moins deux
rats par un qui datait de 2007 l'autre
de 2018 qui mettait le doigt et souligné
sa vulnérabilité et donc nous
considérons desjardins n'a pas bien
qu'elle avait un plan pour y remédier il
n'a pas agi assez rapidement pour
colmater ces brèches et donc si
desjardins savait dès 2017 qu'il se
passait ça présentement qui avait cette
vulnérabilité est ce qu'elle était
capable d'agir pour contrer
oui quand même certaines mesures qui
auraient pu être prises plus rapidement
par exemple de bloquer les ports usb
pour éviter que des employés puisque au
pied des grands volumes des grandes
quantités de renseignements personnels
sur des supports externes comme des des
clés usb
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
aurait été dû être fait plus rapidement
on pense aussi qu'elle aurait dû exercer
inclut une plus grande surveillance
proactive des activités pour détecter
des activités inhabituelles par exemple
qui avait lieu donc est ce que vous
considérez que ça aurait été simple de
faire ça c'est sûr que c'est il ya
certains éléments qui sont pas si
simples mais bloquer les ports usb et
est quand même quelque chose de
relativement simple mais simple ou non
c'est quelque chose qui aurait dû être
fait depuis longtemps mais est ce que
c'est de la négligence même en fait
c'est sûr que dans la mesure où on
conclut que desjardins n'a pas agi avec
diligence et prudence et en courant de
la situation
et ne pas donc respecter ses obligations
légales c'est notre conclusion les
renseignements de 4 millions même un peu
plus de 4 millions de clients non actifs
était toujours accessible ça remonte à
il ya longtemps il y avait vraiment des
dossiers qui remontait à plusieurs
dizaines d'années si je me trompe pas
combien de temps une institution
financière peut garder les données de
ses clients
en fait ce qui est particulier c'est
qu'en vertu de la législation québécoise
sur la protection des renseignements
personnels
il n'existe aucune obligation pour une
entreprise financière ou autre de
détruire des renseignements on comprend
avec l'incident de desjardins
en croatie tout à fait essentiel d'avoir
une telle obligation
la seule obligation qui existe dans la
loi actuelle c'est de cesser d'utiliser
quand ils sont plus nécessaires on fait
les quartiers où effectivement parce que
nous on peut pas ordonner en tout cas de
les détruire en vertu des dispositions
actuelles l'oeil à un projet de loi qui
est l étude à québec en ce moment sur la
protection des données notamment le
projet de loi 64 est ce qu'on prévoit
mieux protégés justement les données des
clients et des clients d'un actif oui
justement il est proposé dans le projet
de loi de pallier à cette lacune et de
d'imposer aux autres aux entreprises une
obligation de détruire les
renseignements personnels
une fois qu'ils sont plus nécessaires à
l'exercice de leur activité
il ya aussi évidemment on en a beaucoup
parlé des mesures des sanctions
administratives pécuniaires ou des
sanctions pénales qu'on espère
dissuasive et convient présentement
c'est au tour de 10000 dollars en ce
moment c'est un maximum de dix mille
dollars mais seulement pour une plainte
pénale une poursuite pénale
on ne peut pas actuellement le pouvoir
d'imposer des sanctions administratives
pécuniaires et des jardins aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'une sanction non parce qu'on
n'a pas le pouvoir d'imposer une
sanction actuellement et la poursuite
pénale et était peu probable la réussite
d'une poursuite pénale était peu
probable parce que délai de prescription
est dans une maintenant pour faire une
enquête d'une telle ampleur est déjà
trop tôt des essais sa première
dpcp d'évaluer aussi le dossier c'est
clair que le taux de succès était peu
probable et le projet doit amènerait les
sanctions à combien pour des sanctions
pénales ce serait de jusqu'à une
possibilité de 25 millions de dollars ou
4 % du chiffre d'affaires mondial et
pour les sanctions administratives
pécuniaires 10 millions de dollars et 2
% ou 2 % du chiffre d'affaires mondial
selon le coût élevé des deux montants
donc pas de sanction pour pour manque de
prudence là pour pour être gentil on va
dire comme ça est ce que les données qui
ont été volés ou déplacées ou capter
dans cette clé usb en ce moment son
protégé détruite où elles peuvent encore
circulé en fait notre enquête comme elle
vise le respect par desjardins de ses
obligations
c'est pas un volet on n'a pas su fait
suivi regardez le suivi ou sont rendus
les données je pense ça relève davantage
de l' enquête policière mais pour
répondre à votre question c'est tout à
fait plausible de penser que ces données
existe quelque part qu'elles sont
peut-être vendu sur le dark web ou à wil
ou autrement c'est pas tellement
rassurant est ce que le soutien offert
par desjardins à sa clientèle en ce
moment là ils suffisants notamment avec
equifax si sûr que d'abord chaud sous
unix est important d'offrir une
protection aux victimes de ce genre
d'incident pour leur permettre de
surveiller toute activité inhabituelle
par exemple sur leur dossier de crédit à
la commission on n'a pas examiné en
détail les mesures de protection qui
sont offertes par desjardins pour la
simple et bonne raison qu'ils aient pas
d'obligation dans la loi actuelle pour
l'instant pour une entreprise qui
croient qu'il ya un incident comme celui
là de nous le déclarer de déclarer aux
victimes ou de minimiser les préjudices
qui sont susceptibles d'en résulter
alors mon collègue mon le commissariat
fédéral à la protection de la vie privée
lui a abordé cette question là dans son
rapport parce que ces obligations lors
existe dans la loi fédérale
cent déclarent satisfaits diane poitras
va s'arrêter ici merci pour ces
explications ce soir merci au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]